the next one we come to is hidali nagali
kaishi
this one um you need to know a few
things
it's not just a cat
and around to the other side
and the ski no sorry not scared in there
it's just uh
well we'll do it and see
same feeling as the second suburb
with the ken strike
place the hand directly to the side of
you
move the hips place it
in the hand so it's the power of your
hips
don't just don't just put your hand like
that
move your hips
[Music]
now what i'm going to do now is i use a
block
so i want to shift my weight which is my
weight as i turn my
feet and block
with my left hand i just give it a
little bit of energy
[Music]
the problem is when we do it as one
if you break it down like this you
realize there's a block there
when you do it with movement we very
often
don't put the block in it just becomes
like one big full movement
so we have to be careful it doesn't
become this
there's no block or shifting of your
balance
so
is
okay so there's a lot of work a lot of
movement in there
and then you put it together but
remember
the block must still be in there that
feeling of blocking must stop in there
even when on the move
so it could be weak here
but if your block
is strong it's still a block it's not
here where your head is
above about this
this is above your head
so it's protecting from a strike to the
side
so please watch this in slow motion
as well
watch how the feet slowly turn on the
balls of the feet
i push my left hand
in this direction there's a clock and my
jaw is at 12.
i push to 2 o'clock
my hips
shift the weight
so
the hands stay in front of me
not this this is incorrect
this is incorrect and my hands are in
front of the jar
the joe needs to be in front of the
hands
and above the head
get down in the garden guys huge
guys means rest nagari
is the flow of the speed
one mother point i'd like to talk about
that i forgot
in the hassos is
when you're in this feeling i said about
pushing out
and looking under in the old ocean sea
films you'll see
scentsy here and he he does like a
ice cream cone movement
he's going up gathering the energy from
the universe and he pulls it inside him
you should get this cone feeling
when coming into the hasso i forgot to
tell you that so
go right back to square one on the
hasso's
and uh try to find that understanding
does about what when you do this feeling
here
this feeling here is that cone
so on the the two shearer ones
please try and find this cone okay so
yellow but i
try to feel this cone-like feeling
coming
first you do it with your hands and then
it should feel like your whole body is
doing it
and toes
for the tip of the jaw
this will give you the energy and the
key that uh you should find in your like
it's not just pleasure it's it's joy
from the heart
because you're becoming one with an item
and the item becomes one with you and
then you become one with the
energy that you possess and and also
take from the atmosphere and put into
the technique
don't wanna get my stuff